[Musique]
à l'occasion de la journée
internationale de la femme rurale le
président du département cyrille
melchior a visité un marché des
productrices organisée par la commission
des agricultrices de la fdsea dans les
jardins de la saga du rhum à saint
pierre le 15 octobre
elle joue un rôle essentiel dans le
développement du col de marie mais de
tout le temps et plus encore joies du
peut-être parce que nous sommes à une
période les femmes participent à
l'innovation et ont cet esprit de
créativité
qui font que la réunion avance la
réunion on reste dans le domaine de la
culture
nous avons de plus en plus de produits
transformés
par le savoir faire des femmes
réunionnaises une journée conviviale qui
met à l'honneur ces femmes qui
travaillent sans relâche aux couleurs de
l'album hobo salle et sur les marchés
vous allez toujours voir un monsieur dr
l'attaquent mais chez lui il ya toujours
une femme derrière tu vas toujours
équivalent et dès que ça dans les champs
ça soit dans les préparatifs dans les
papiers etc donc c'est bien de mettre à
l'honneur les femmes également prémat
patch et agricultrices spécialisée dans
la production et la transformation de
pita ya remporté le prix du savoir faire
à l'occasion de la cérémonie de remise
du trophée des agricultrices du mot mais
là c'est la reconnaissance vraiment de
mon travail parce que c'est madame qui
dans l'atelier qui confectionnent les
confitures et sirops les jeunes et
et donc là
[Musique]
non seulement on épouse maman et on est
aussi chaque entreprise
fait de notre travail agricole au niveau
agricole à nous s'occupait aussi les
papiers pas que de nous mais aussi tout
ce qui est administratif du monsieur et
les enfants reposent aussi sur nous donc
on l'a jamais de repos ce petit marchand
politique et mais c'est un métier
la politique départementale en faveur de
l'agriculture s'appuie sur un budget
annuel de 20 millions d'euros
[Musique]